et sapins de noël finissent leur vie en
toute splendeur
c'est le temps des failles elle tourne
dans la nuit pour nous rappeler le
rythme des saisons une fête que les plus
anciens célébré dès leur plus jeune âge
tout commence ici à la cabane des
chasseurs là ceux qui savent encore
montre aux plus jeunes les gestes
traditionnels un manche en tilleul parce
qu'il se sent bien et des copeaux de
fresnes parce qu'il brûle bien c'est que
les jeunes nous remplace parce qu'on
commence à prendre de l'âge
c'est assez difficile quoi seigneur
penny cette faille la fête païenne s'est
invité chez les chrétiens by brûle
faille tremble chante les paroissiens
avant de se mêler à la foule des grands
soirs
façon de se retrouver de se souhaiter
les voeux en tout début d'année autour
du feu comme le faisaient nos anciens
[Musique]
une foule venue aussi pour les artifices
les étoiles sont éclipsés mais c'est
elle qui auront le dernier mot
elle veille sur le bûcher seuls les plus
aguerris comme gaël le bris plongent
leurs failles dans son ventre
depuis il j'ai 8 ans je tourne les
failles mais je participe à la fête des
failles depuis même encore avant
c'est vraiment la fête traditionnelle de
mon village pour rien on mangera très ça
en fait
et pour ne pas risquer de disparaître la
fête de mutti hautepierre s'ouvre au
monde nouvelle venue
les lanternes offrent leur magie à tous
les guillou c'est le nom des habitants
ont le sens de l'accueil
on n'a pas dit si c'est la première fois
qu'on vient et franchement c'est super
sympa la fête des failles cultive à un
certain art de vivre
entre tradition et modernité
[Musique]